I'm Conrad Fisher no way are you serious
yeah like Conrad you're a bit of a Clos
book you're incredibly hard to read and
you keep your feelings close to the vest
which means that even the people you
love most feel like they don't really
know where they stand with you the truth
is under the surface you're incredibly
vulnerable with a huge heart and all you
want is to protect the people you care
about and every once in a while you let
them care about you too I feel like
that's so funny cuz didn't we all say
that he was like the furthest from this
character but that but that makes sense
that's a really sweet description I like
the description well
uh you are Conrad
Fisher
wow what yeah I genuinely didn't expect
that but I I mean that you'll see my
reaction I literally went
hope I did not expect that but yeah